each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
okay the final speaker for this session
is to new char from Queensland
University of Technology shall we talk
about making sense of sequences
comparative genomics at the new gps say
thank you very much for joining me so my
name is singing and i'm from the
microsoft q te research center from
Brisbane Australia so we're in the
bioinformatics department where
developed pings and tools and
applications that will help scientists
in making sense of sequences and in the
area of comparative genomics and the new
GSG is so quick overview of the talk
today I'll begin with the introduction
of the difficulties that current
biologists are having and introduce the
bow two point oh so our solutions in how
we're going to attempt to overcome these
difficulties and address the problems so
bringing in the GIS to comparative
genomics and conclude with our plans for
the future so with the new and improving
development of sequencing machines such
as 454 we've got an explosion in the
genomic data that's available now
especially in the last ten years
illustrator in the graph there so what
we have there is looking at sequences
and scale of the number in millions
available that's in the genbank database
so basically it's the rise of population
genomics and proteomics so it's great
that we're having all this data
available but what do these sequences
mean when I find a new gene what's the
function of this gene why do I have one
species that's so alike to another but
what is it that's making them so
different so these are the type of
questions that biologists wants to
answer when they're trying to make sense
of these sequences and a common approach
that they use is through comparative
genomics where they take a region of the
DNA
a protein sequence and make comparisons
against each other across a number of G
notes so I just want to use a simple
example so else starting from common
ground and this is a common approach
used when looking for similar genes
trying to through protein
characterizations so trying to find out
the function of a particular gene so I
start off with my gene of interest there
put it through blast which is the common
tool that's available from NCBI so
that's a screenshot and what blast
returns is a list of hits with each one
with an Associated eval you so that's
similar a little similar genes so this
is an example output what I'll do is
just ok so that's clearer so at the top
you have a summary of the results that
you get and here is a list of the arm
results each of them have a name of the
gene and as I mentioned before the
associated eval you score there if we
keep scrolling down for each one of
these hits that we get we also have more
information and the actual alignment
view showing the position actual
position similarity and differences back
with our starting gene so that's again
summarized in this picture this is the
result of one gene comparison now let's
look at something that's in the tens
regions so we start to get a lot more
alignment and imagine if we're doing an
M by M minus 1 gene comparison against a
number of organisms so specific example
is for my own PhD research where I'm
going to be studying you're sending up
esters which is the cause of plague not
a very nice little bug there against
ecole lime and both of them have over
four thousand genes so you start to get
the idea that its information overload
and it's just too hard to comprehend in
tech space output there so want to make
it I want to make a note that we do
understand that this text based
alignment is important to the biologist
but
prior to stepping straight to this
alignment let's take a step back and let
the scientists look visualize it in a
graph we want to have a look at the
distribution of the genes that are
similar to what we started with so we
make the topology fit the question and
we take advantage that visualization is
the key to navigation so what I mean by
that is there are certain details or
patterns and clusters that you can see
quickly that you can spot easily when
you're looking at a graph as opposed to
the previous example where it's all text
based so this can lead the scientists to
refining and testing their hypotheses
and when they reach an answer that the
happy with or they come to a new
discovery we provide them with
functionality for them to share their
views with their peers or with a
collaborator that situated across the
globe and we provide this with more than
a static image and more than the print
screen button so I'll demo this in a few
slides so the beauty of our approach is
that we're using a concept that's been
around for a long time it was developed
before even I was born so the idea of
that is that the users don't have to
learn something completely new so we're
familiar with the GIS we're comfortable
when we look at maps we look we know the
distance it E sorry as dots on the maps
and with when we think of maps we think
of distances but in when we apply GIS to
our application with comparative
genomics the dots there are genes and
the distances represent the similarities
between the two genes so in addition to
that we also linked to a collection of
other data sources through bio to IDF
and this is our new G is so this time is
the genomic information system
they've been talking about our system
and what we're trying to address here
and I haven't even mentioned the name so
our system there is called silver map so
named because it's been implemented in
Silverlight I'm Silverlight as client
base so it's fast or we do send the data
across and all the rendering it happens
on client-side Silverlight also provides
a richer environment so we make use of
this in implementing animations which
will help in data comprehension for the
scientists and this will all become
apparent in the demo so here's a
schematic of our model silver map is
linked to the bio to rdf repository
which is also used with tags so users
can put their own annotations in there
our first one is the blast component
which we have a local copy of but
essentially we will have it linked up to
ncbi blast as well as sometimes
scientists would like to perform their
own blast on their local machine so
we'll have that implemented and
supported now I keep talking about
distances for users and using the blast
as an example but essentially our go
list so that the user can provide their
own defined distances and implement that
and that will take over the blast
component and so if I kept talking about
how distances represent the similarity
between genes another example where the
distance between do genes actually
doesn't mean anything is in
transcription regulatory networks and
modeling protein-protein interactions so
what we have there is the distance
between two genes don't necessarily mean
anything but the directed edge from one
gene to another is significant because
we want to capture that relationship in
there so another advantage of
silverlight as i mentioned previously
the animations and the ability to
dynamic dynamically highlight the sub
networks of these two models again helps
data comprehension
for scientists so without further ado
I'll have a look at the demo so just
coming back to this example blast output
here which I've already done previously
is showing the output of one gene and
finding similarities of that gene but
what we don't get from this output is
that how closely related are these
students to each other so I've done that
using our local blast database so these
are the results and i did the blast and
just keeping a traditional approach
these are the actual sequence based
alignments but we'll jump over silver
map so this is silver map we're keeping
the sort of familiar interface with that
you'll see with maps and navigation
buttons and what we have in the center
is the gene that I'm interested in so I
can zoom in just using my mouse
scrolling in so this gene is found in
your senior pastors it's sort of known
to play a role in violence but we don't
know its particular function so the idea
is to find similar genes and try to
infer a function for this one that I'm
interested in now I've mentioned about
the animations so if i don't like this
reference gene what the distance is that
i kept mentioning about is in relation
to all these ones on the outside so this
is the radial distance between the nodes
on the outside to the scent of it so
that's been represented by the e value
which is down here so what i can do is
if i don't like that reference gene i
can change the view by double clicking
and that navigates to the center and
everything else models around it so i
can get that immediate response and i
can analyze the data so
do another animation there is that each
individual sort of thinks differently
depending on the type of animation so in
this one where we select the reference
dream that we were interested in it
jumps to the center and everything else
navigates around it I myself don't
particular follow that quite well so
what we can go on the fly is where you
select your gene and everything else
moves to that so you've got all these
different types of animations there for
the user and that again helps them
comprehend their data so come back to
this one so again I was saying in the
beginning that I'm trying to infer the
function of this gene here but what I
want to do is to just focus on the genes
that are really close to this one so
what I have is this radius which is a
threshold cut off which will dynamically
move that red dashed circle so I just
want to focus on the genes inside that
red circle and down here I've got a
summary of all the genes that are in
that circle which tells me quick notes
about them
and if I just zoom in so each note there
has labeled and those with the asterisks
have an associated tag that's been
previously annotated and let's just have
a look at what this one has so the tags
it's a membrane protein so I'm just
going to copy that with ctrl c I'm going
to go in my tags so in silver Matt we
also have tagging where we can select
use to select subnets so these have the
ones that I highlighted in blue have all
been tagged with e.coli so the one that
I was interested in is membrane protein
so we already know that these three
actual membrane proteins so what i can
do is make an inference that maybe the
once all there in the center there could
be membrane proteins i just want to tag
all the genes in the center
to supply the tag
okay they've all been tagged so that
asterisk is coming up there's no and it
appears down here with account so
previously I was one last thing is that
i was mentioning how we can collaborate
and share this view so if the science is
happy with this view what they can do is
the ability to come down to the HTML
screenshot panel which produce this div
object I can select all that copy it
heck copy that and then go to my virtual
lab wiki page or a HTML put that into
the HTML and what it will produce is a
widget mode so this is a actual live
HTML page so it's about your sending up
Esther's the bug that I'm working on for
my PhD but what we have down here is the
actual widget mode of silver mats and
it's fully operational so you get the
zooming different navigations and you
can also have set different thresholds
so you can simply do that configure your
web page use the URL and then send that
off in an email to your collaborators
they come to this page it also it always
loads on that default
k
so just to conclude our future
directions where we're headed so as I
mentioned before it's not just about
similarity between genes ideally we want
the user to come up with their own
distances and we want to support that we
want to also look at modeling
transcription regulatory networks and
protein-protein interactions with silver
maps and basically so bring our tools to
the community so being able to make
silver map the lingua franca of genomic
publications as I mentioned the demoed
with the virtual lab book and the public
website so integration with tagging and
sharing of views and just one quick demo
that what we also tried in the previous
week was because scientists are so used
to excel and spreadsheet so we looked at
a member of our group looked at the
possibility of integrating the
silverlight component into excel this is
another one of our tools called silver
gene it's also implemented in
silverlight it's more mature than our
Maps tool but basically what this is
showing is you've got you can load up
different genomes so to traditional
genome type browser I can note down to
sequence views but it's links so i can
change the view of the window on my
excel form and it will dynamically
propagate that to the genome there and I
can add different tracks to this now
again it will come up and the user has
all the computer ability to change the
view and move about so the same idea
there will apply to silver map so we
look into the ability of incorporating
that as well
ah
okay hey so I'll slide just like to
thank Queensland University of
Technology and funding from Microsoft
Research and queensland state government
and Microsoft Research given me the
opportunity to come and represent my
group and give an introduction of what
we've been working on and thank you very
much for listening thank you very much
we have to offer a couple of questions
so so we've thought about using
silverlight no just curious how easy
difficult it was um it's for us it was
actually fairly easy because it's a
familiar csharp environment so we we
didn't have to learn a whole new
language around it was a familiar
environment to you so yeah it wasn't too
difficult so move over to silverlight
okay it's silverlight one that you used
ah we started from the beta release so
we went from silverlight one and then
when the new one came out we had to
transfer everything over so the the one
that i demoed there is the current
silver like to yeah any more questions
okay I'll ask the usual one where is
this available from can we download it
can use it and that one is you don't
need to download it's actually just on
browser so this is normal IE browser
well you just need to download the
silverlight plugin but this one is a
better release its not publicly
available yet but we're releasing it
soon in january so you can never get to
it from our website so that's the Qt one
that we can see in the toolbar oh that's
awesome yeah QT makuta cutie edu at you
so it will be out very very soon and I
think silver jeans or D yes silver jeans
already out okay okay well thank you
very much and please join me in thanking
all the speakers